let's consider an example of motion
which we want to use our energy concepts
so suppose we have a ramp which is
circular radius R and we have an object
here and now here's a surface a certain
distance D that has friction where the
coefficient of friction is non-uniform
so we'll write it as mu naught and we'll
write it as mu 1 X we'll take x equals 0
and then here there's a spring and a
wall and here there's no friction now as
we drop assuming we have enough height
here H so that this block will slide
across the friction make it all the way
across and start compressing its spring
what I'd like to find is how much the
spring has been compressed
okay now how do we analyze this well the
key is to use our energy principle where
we have W external equals the change in
mechanical energy and the key is to what
we're going to do is the tool that we're
going to use is what we call energy
diagrams for the initial so what does
this mean we want to choose we want to
first identify the initial and final
States that we're referring to
so in our picture here's our initial
state and I'll draw the final state end
when the spring has been compressed a
distance X final so I drew it on my
diagram so we have initial and final
States and now what we want to do is
choose reference points 0 points 0 point
for each potential function
and show that on our diagram so for the
potential energy of gravity here if we
chose this to be Y then this is y equals
0 and U at y equals 0 is 0 and we'll
call that the zero point for gravity and
the zero point for the spring is when
this X now I'm gonna call here x equals
zero so let's call this a variable I can
call it anything I want I'll call it U
final and this is where u is 0 so u
final just measures its the stretch of
the spring and so at y equals 0 is 0 and
u spring a little view equals 0 0 so now
I can identify my energies so let's talk
about the initial energy is all
gravitational potential
that's mg Y it's starting at rest and be
final well here this is the distance
where it comes to rest also so there's
no final kinetic energy
there's no gravitational potential
energy because we're on the surface at y
equals 0 but our spring has been
compressed by 1/2 K little u final
squared now in terms of our external
work equals the change in mechanical
energy we have now identified the
right-hand side using these tools of the
energy diagrams and I can write my
description u final squared minus mg Y
now what I have to do is think about the
friction force F kinetic friction as the
object moves this friction force is non
uniform if we were to draw an nNG
then our friction force here is equal to
the integral minus the integral from x
equals zero to x equals d x equals zero
to x equal d of the friction force which
is equal to the coefficient of friction
mu K and D X now that zero to D notice
that our coefficient of friction is
varying and I tells that intentionally
just show you that friction is really an
integral so we have mu naught plus mu 1
X M G DX let's put our integration
variable in there and these are just two
separate integrals the first one is easy
it's minus mu naught mg D and the second
one is minus mu 1 mg and we're just
integrating X prime DX Prime between 0
and D so that's simply d squared over 2
and that's equal to K U final squared
minus mg Y let's write that as Y initial
and we're starting it at Y initial
equals H and so even though this is
complicated
I can now solve for how much this spring
has been compressed with a little bit of
algebra and so I'm just going to bring a
bunch of terms over to the other side
and take the square root of 2 divided by
K of mg y initial
- you not MGD minus mu-1 mg d squared
over 2 and that's how much the spring is
compressed notice what I did not do was
divide this up into a bunch of different
motions I picked an initial state I
picked the final state
I drew my energy diagrams with my 0
points I described the key parameters of
the initial and final States why I and
you fine
final I defined the initial mechanical
energy
the final mechanical energy and then
applied the work energy work mechanical
energy principle I had to integrate the
friction force because it was
non-trivial and solve for how much the
spring has been compressed